[Music]
on this final friday of the election
campaign the pursuit of political
supremacy
the liberals quest to push supporters to
the ballot box the conservative leader's
refusal to acknowledge alberta's premier
it was like he'd never heard of the guy
and the ndp on the offense in quebec
revolting against a culture of misogyny
western university students take a stand
by walking out for women and a new fight
for afghanistan veterans their mission
to have a comrade bestowed with canada's
highest military honor
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight bara nasser good
evening and thank you for joining us it
is the final push before the federal
election and what's shaping up to be one
of the closest races in recent history
these next 48 hours will be critical for
candidates to convince the many voters
who are still on the fence our
correspondents are traveling with the
candidates as they try and get out the
vote abigail beeman is with the liberal
leader who's looking to hang on to his
job and form a majority
michael couture is alongside the tories
who are distancing themselves from the
conservative government in alberta and
robin gill is with the ndp leader
jagmeet singh who just received a high
profile endorsement from former u.s
presidential candidate bernie sanders
but we begin tonight with abigail and
the liberals and their challenges on the
home stretch
back in southern ontario means justin
trudeau is back face to face with angry
protesters
these people certainly won't be voting
liberal but the party has a bigger
challenge more broadly getting those who
will out to the polls there seems to be
a slight advantage for the conservative
party among those older voters in terms
of conservative older voters being more
committed to voting than liberal older
voters ipsos pollster daryl bricker says
the most important demographic trend is
not about party but turnout even at the
best of times canadians are never very
enthusiastic about an election so i
understand
the frustration experts say that
frustration is also a problem for
potential liberal voters potentially
voting for another party but more more
likely just saying you know what i'm
just going to sit this one out i
actually don't even think it's safe for
me to go vote i forgot to register for a
mail-in ballot from day one trudeau has
refused to say he's out to win a
majority he came the closest to that
admission on day 34. i'm not going to
engage in hypothetical questions right
now we are focused on winning every seat
i think trudeau is dreaming
and i don't think expressing that
sentiment
actually contributes to swinging votes
saying it clearly or not pushing for a
majority means targeting tight races in
the final push the 905 they're
particularly critical
because it's a vote rich area
and it's often determined whether you
get a liberal or conservative government
and whether that government is minority
or majority the liberals are spending
all day friday and part of the final
weekend targeting tight races in
southern ontario and the 905 both seats
they think they can pick up and ones
they're in danger of losing in fights
with both conservatives and the ndp
abigail beeman global news london
ontario
one riding in the 4-1-6 toronto spadina
fort york is a liberal stronghold but
tonight the party's candidate has been
told to put his campaign on hold the
liberals asked kevin wong to pause as
officials reviewed details around the
crown's move to withdraw a sexual
assault charge against him in 2019.
liberal leader justin trudeau says the
party was not aware of the charge until
just yesterday wong says the allegations
are false and troubling on the home
stretch of the campaign with the ballot
set it is unclear if wang will be
allowed to sit as a liberal if he does
win
like trudeau conservative leader aaron
o'toole spent time in vote rich ontario
today once again dodging questions about
alberta premier jason kenney's handling
of the pandemic and the rising cases
there
in the last election kenny was seen as
an asset flung to ontario to court
conservative voters but this time around
o'toole won't even utter his name
michael couture reports
i know premier's names he knows their
names yet he still won't say jason
kenny's name or comment on whether or
not alberta's premier could have done a
better job managing the covet 19
pandemic in that province as recently as
sunday the federal conservative leader
praised his provincial counterpart
even though kenny has admitted mistakes
o'toole won't weigh in in our collective
fight against kovid 19 i will work with
provinces and premiers of all political
stripes it was like he'd never heard of
the guy did jason who i i don't know who
this jason guy is political science
professor dwayne bratt says o'toole is
in a tough spot because kenny's support
helped make him leader of the federal
conservatives the kovit 19 crisis and
alberta is hurting the tories and that
could mean fewer seats in that province
you could have a very bizarre situation
where aaron o'toole actually picks up
seats in other parts of the country and
loses them in his base and if he does
it's not necessarily because of o'toole
it's because of jason kenney
a part of the problem is vote splitting
with the far right people's party of
canada it's likely why o'toole has been
trying to hammer home a new message to
canadians there are many parties in this
race but there's really only two choices
more of the same with mr trudeau or
canada's conservatives that black and
white choice is key in motivating voters
according to this conservative
strategist it is about making sure that
those who have shown they're accessible
to voting for you are actually going to
turn up on election day especially given
how long lines are going to be o'toole's
team believes getting to those voters is
better by bus so they've ditched the
plane and will concentrate campaigning
in the vote rich toronto and southern
ontario regions hoping it will pave the
way to forming government
farah
michael couture in brantford ontario
thank you mike
alberta's new daily cases have now
topped 2 thousand for the first time
since may critics say this surge could
have been avoided if the premier made
tougher decisions sooner jason kenney
says the situation shouldn't be about
politics or personalities it should be
about protecting hospitals
demand for icu beds has never been
higher and within 10 days it could
exceed capacity and now the calls are
growing even louder for premier kenny to
resign not just from his political
opponents but from inside his own party
too tom vernon joins us now from
edmonton with more on this tom
farah there have been rumblings of
discontent with premier kenny for months
now last spring a website was launched
by grassroots members called kenny must
go it started collecting signatures
calling for just that two mlas were also
kicked out of caucus in the spring for
publicly speaking out against the
premier one of them directly calling for
his resignation now premier kenny had
hoped his open for summer plan open for
good plan would quiet down that
discontent and it did for a number of
weeks but with the fourth wave of 19
hitting alberta so hard the discontent
has come back to the forefront i've been
told by a constituency association
president that motions for a leadership
review are being discussed in
constituency associations right across
the province his association has passed
when he says their concerns come from
top down leadership style not listening
to the grassroots oh and that infamous
meal on top of the sky palace patio
breaking rules with fellow cabinet
ministers a level of entitlement that my
constituency association could not stand
uh even some of our board members who
were
not as critical of premier kenny up to
that point from that point on absolutely
felt as if that was the final straw
tom this all comes while alberta's
health system is really at the breaking
point i mean the province is asking for
help from other parts of canada even
today alberta frontline staff protested
demanding improvements to the province's
health care system so what are the
doctors and nurses they're saying tom
well they're saying it should not have
gotten to this point they've been
calling for weeks for a vaccine passport
type system premier kenny had been
resisting that call for weeks but
finally relented this week due to the
rising cases in the icu we're also
suffering through a severe staff
shortage for health care workers here in
the province nurses doctors they're even
looking at contracting private ones from
outside the province now they are
contract negotiations ongoing between
the government and nurses as well not
helping in this they are tense the
government was seeking a wage rollback
we could see a strike vote in a matter
of weeks
farah
tom vernon in edmonton thank you tom the
ndp made a campaign stop today in quebec
optimistic about gaining back seats in a
province where the party's popularity
has been declining leader jagmeet singh
defended the ndp's environmental plan
and as robin gill reports he targeted
young voters too
in the affable style that has become his
signature jagmeet singh makes his way to
convince students in sherbert quebec to
vote for his party
it's the first time the ndp leader has
been to this riding during the campaign
how attainable are these three ridings
for the new democrats
we're very hopeful we're very excited
very optimistic the ndp's popularity in
quebec has sunk from a decade ago when
it was at its peak the liberals won
sherbrooke in
and they took sackville then how you
feeling
halifax too they're trying to pick up
seats in areas where they're not present
at the moment
but there's methods to this last bit of
campaigning in these ridings says a
former ndp strategist it sends a
positive message elsewhere in the
country that you're campaigning in seats
where at the beginning of the campaign
people would think you did not have a
chance to win
up next saskatoon for riding the n.g.p
loss by less than 3 000 votes in 2019
then it's off to edmonton for the one
riding the party secured the last time
around in a province that is
traditionally true blue robin gill
global news dartmouth nova scotia
and donna friesen will anchor our
extensive coverage on election night
monday right here on global tv as well
as on history global news radio and
various online platforms including of
course globalnews.ca
some sad news out of ontario tonight the
top doctor in the waterloo region says a
child under the age of 10 has died from
covid19 related issues the child is the
youngest person in the region to die
from the virus
this is a rare but tragic circumstance
and a devastating reminder of the
serious nature of this virus
this is a heartbreaking loss
doctors say the child had underlying
health conditions and there were no
school-related or daycare-related
exposures
the criminal case involving canada's
former top soldier has been adjourned
until mid-october retired general
jonathan vance is charged with
obstruction of justice in relation to a
military investigation into misconduct
allegations made against him accusations
he denies court documents suggest vance
made repeated attempts to persuade a
female officer who told global news that
she had an intimate relationship with
him to make false statements to
investigators
thousands of ontario students walked out
at western university today to show
their support for victims and survivors
of gender-based violence they're
protesting what they say is a culture of
misogyny at the school after a series of
sexual assault allegations in recent
days
as brittany rosen reports they're
demanding the university do more to
protect them
it's a cry for an end to gender-based
violence and sexual assaults an issue
some here referred to as an epidemic
that has plagued western university
following a series of sexual assault
allegations during the first week of
school that have allegedly targeted up
to 30 female students people gathered
here to stand in solidarity with victims
and survivors including brynn had i come
forward earlier would the institution
have done anything to help prevent
future incidents from occurring
of course
none of these sentiments mattered after
learning that up to 30
lives had been forever altered
students made signs hung messages of
support and vocalized their concerns
about campus safety do you know what
it's like to walk past the site of the
most traumatic experience of your life
every day just to get to class this just
one of numerous unsettling accounts from
those who go to school here being silent
about this problem is perpetuating this
culture and i just hope that
from today there can be changes made
at the peak of the protest campus police
reported up to 9 000 participants
thousands of students here are calling
on the university to do more to address
what they are calling a culture problem
among their demands they want to see a
survivor-centric approach to handling
reports of gender-based violence and
sexual assault we want a safe space for
dialogue and support for survivors which
the university has failed to provide as
for staff at western they say they too
are well aware of students experiences
the incidents of the past week and you
being here today
tell us that you do not feel safe while
counseling and other supports remain in
place on campus western had since
created a task force to handle
gender-based violence and student safety
brittany rosen global news
a heartwarming reunion between a boy and
his dad in canada coming up how the
afghanistan crisis tore them apart
an afghan man and his little boy have
been reunited in canada after spending
months apart
the two were united monday at toronto's
pearson airport the toddler was
separated from his family during the
mayhem at kabul airport last month turns
out he'd been put on a plane to qatar
and remained there until officials were
able to track him down speaking through
an interpreter the boy's father says the
reunion has been unbelievable
he cannot put his feelings into words
but he was really really happy when he
saw his son
the boy's mother and four siblings
remain in afghanistan but the father is
hopeful that they too will come to
canada
still had accusations of islamophobia on
the campaign trail and the candidate
who's firing back
as we hit the home stretch of this
election campaign we're looking at some
of the first-time candidates and the
backstories behind their political drive
mike armstrong introduces us to ensef
heider the block candidate in sherbrooke
quebec and human rights activist whose
husband is imprisoned in saudi arabia
the public part of politics isn't new
for ensof hyder
for years she's toured the world
speaking about her husband's
imprisonment calling for his release
freedom of expression is one of the
things she wants to push in parliament
if i have a voice in the house of
commons in ottawa she says i will use
that voice
now it was her husband's voice that
landed him in prison rayef badawi a
writer in saudi arabia was arrested in
2012. for the crime of insulting islam
he was sentenced to 10 years and a
thousand lashes
this was badawi in 2015 getting the
first 50 lashes
hydra says seeing that video was hard
but that she was less concerned about
the physical pain her husband was
feeling than the mental toll of his
imprisonment
hydra moved to canada as a refugee with
the couple's three children they've
lived in sherbert quebec since 2013.
she says she's been asked often why
someone who's been in canada for less
than a decade and a citizen for barely
three years would run for the black
quebecois a party that's working to
break up the country
heider says she is thankful to canada
but that she found her independence in
quebec and feels quebec should find its
independence
i'm a citizen like everyone else she
says i have the right to choose
heider has come under heavy criticism
for getting too close to the far right
she's been accused of being islamophobic
she supported maxim bernier's people's
party of canada before the last election
in 2019 she met with prominent
anti-muslim activist robert spencer
calling him a good friend and earlier
this year tweeted criticism of the cbc
for hiring a journalist who wears a
hijab saying quote it started like that
in iran
islamophobia haider says islamophobia
doesn't exist and as for supporting
controversial figures she argued simply
they were nice to her so she was nice to
them
now there appears to be some discomfort
in the party about some of those
positions campaigning in the riding with
the leader of the block reporters tried
to ask haider questions
didn't let her speak while he was there
saying it wasn't the time but since then
she hasn't held back
mike armstrong global news sherbert
quebec
next the fight to get the highest honor
for a canadian war hero
canada has always put humility before
showmanship when it comes to celebrating
our armed forces
the u.s australia britain and new
zealand all awarded their top military
honors to afghanistan war veterans but
as mike delay explains a group of
canadian veterans including former chief
of the defense staff general rick
hillier is hoping to change that and
soon
the agony of this moment must have been
unbearable for private jess larochelle
saying goodbye to two good friends all
the while in physical agony
you
broke your back yet you still carried
the casket the next day at the ramp
ceremony yeah i was having trouble
walking and that and
the warning officer told me to go to
the hospital and i said after i
carried blake or darcy's casket i'll go
right away private blake williamson and
sergeant darcy tedford were killed by
the taliban securing a road construction
project in afghanistan in 2006.
lara shell survived the attack if only
barely fifteen years later la rochelle's
injuries have caught up with him he
spoke with us from a hospital bed in
north bay about a group of afghanistan
veterans who are trying to right a wrong
la rochelle the group says should have
been awarded the canadian victoria cross
the taliban attack was swift
and he was knocked unconscious by an rpg
when he came to his back was broken as
was his gun and over 20 taliban fighters
were approaching he found a pile of 15
m72 rocket launchers and fired them all
off one by one from what i understand
that his firing with the rockets was so
accurate that he was hitting them
directly and that maybe also indicate
just how close they were and we in my
view would have lost a lot of canadians
that day that we did not lose because of
just
just
larichelle's valor canada hasn't awarded
a victoria cross since 1945. general
rick hillier admits the committee that
decided on medals in afghanistan has
been conservative in its decision-making
so now he along with other veterans have
sent a letter to the governor general
asking for larochelle's case to be
reviewed before his health declines
further things are not looking good for
guests
if you're going to
do something like this and you want
because jess would be extremely
honored
that you know to get it as a alive
don't ask me how he would feel once he's
passed so now the battle is with
government bureaucracy but la rochelle
has faced overwhelming odds before
mike relay global news toronto
and that is it for global national for
this friday night i'm farah nasser thank
you so much for spending part of your
evening with us tonight's your canada is
kananaskis alberta we love seeing your
canada so please keep emailing us your
pictures at viewers at
globalnational.com
nitu garcia will be at the anchor desk
over the weekend and i'm going to see
you on monday night alongside donna
friesen for global's extensive election
coverage until then take care of
yourselves and each other
[Music]
you